right good evening
let's make a start shall we i just
wonder
am i slacking no that's wonderful okay
thank you okay good evening i'll
introduce myself my name is danny
kendall i'll be chairing tonight's
meeting in accordance with the uh
regulations that's set out in the front
of your agendas tonight
so
um if before we get started on our
planning committee this evening i can
just go through a few bits of general
housekeeping from members of the public
first of all if i could just remind
people to make sure their mobile phones
are turned off or certainly silent so we
don't get any unwanted interruptions in
the middle of the meeting that'll be
fantastic please
secondly just to make sure everyone's
aware that tonight's meeting is being uh
broadcast uh live over our youtube site
and of course will be available for you
to review at your leisure in the next
day or two should you wish to do so
um a couple of notes on covid
regulations if you keep masks on until
you uh
speakers when you come up to the front
please keep masks on until you arrive at
the desk at the front here um and then
of course you if you could just sanitize
your hands and then once you finish
speaking give the table a wipe down
there are wipes on the desk and of
course there's a bin next to it as well
apologies for the covert flummery but
hopefully won't be with us for too much
longer
right okay i think that's all i need to
say there so we move then to item one on
tonight's agenda which is apologies for
absence
chad we have apologies from councillors
richards adams and hendra seraphin
thank you very much
you know what i have forgotten to do
because i'm out of practice i've not
introduced all the people at the front
table apology so i'm just going to pause
for a second i'm going to rewind and do
that if that's okay on my right we have
from committee services olivia quinn on
my left ross james who's our legal
advice tonight and then beyond that we
have alice koznet who's our planning
manager uh alex do you have a statement
you ought to make at this point
thank you chairman
my role is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you
thank you and then across on the way we
have our presenting officers tonight
which dale barker and joseph brooke um
right so apologies for getting that
slightly out of order
we now go back to the committee and when
it is item two disclosure of interests
anyone councillor foreman yes can i i
will be speaking on item four so we'll
withdraw from the table at that point
that's fantastic thank you very much any
other disclosures of interest no
brilliant in that case we're going to go
straight into our first item but before
we get there we've had a couple of
changes in terms of uh the final two
applications that's item six and item
seven so i'm just gonna talk through
those very quickly if that's okay um
first of all i'm proposing actually if
committee are happy that we bring those
two forward to the to this part of the
meeting uh for the obvious reasons i'm
about to about to state so in terms of
item six that's application reference
twenty one slash zero one oh three seven
slash rem
um
but the mem the parish council and the
ward member both withdrew their
objections to that much earlier this
week and consequently that item has
already been delegated back to offices
for a decision so we no longer need to
hear that item tonight so that's item
six
uh in terms of item seven these are two
application references i'll just read
them out briefly
uh twenty one slash zero one five seven
eight slash ful and then the second one
is twenty one slash zero two zero three
four slash l b c
um
none of the we've got no speakers
registered for that and the reason for
that application being here at committee
is because uh it was triggered by an
objection from the ward member of the
parish and the parish council neither of
those people are here to speak tonight
our usual process is in that situation
to delegate that back uh to offices for
a decision we do need to vote on that so
i'm going to take the foot we need to
set vote on them separately though uh so
in terms of the first application that's
21
uh well
zero one five seven eight slash ful
can i have a proposition to delegate
thank you i'll take councillor dixon
second by councillor mills all those in
favor of delegating please unanimous job
thank you and the second which is listed
building consent that's 21 0 2 0 34
lbc can i have a proposition thank you
council jennings and seconder council
dixon all those in favor of delegation
thank you very much okay that was very
smooth brilliant okay right back to the
normal running order so we can then
progress to application so item three
uh which is found on page one of your
agenda
and is application reference twenty one
slash zero one nine one nine slash lbc
this is for number four even caro uh
lower end evan dassett and it's for the
retrospective construction of a
conservatory
presenting officer dale barker dale over
to you
thank you
first of all members there are lengthy
updates with this application i think
you all have an update sheet can i just
confirm that you have read the updates
you've had sufficient time to read and
take them on board
then i'll carry on with the presentation
thank you
um i'd like to remain remind members
that this is a listed building
application and thus the material
considerations are different to planning
applications
um
in that decision makers are required by
law to have special regard to the
desirability of preserving the building
or its setting or any features of
special architectural or historic
interest
and so that's quite different to your
normal procedure
and the application is for a
conservatory which has been on site for
several years the first first
application was refused under delegated
powers and subsequently an appeal was
dismissed a second application was
refused by this committee in february
this year
and this is a third application
effectively for the same conservatory
and if i can just draw members attention
to page
two of the report which gives the
planning history uh on there you'll see
that there is also a current planning
enforcement planning enforcement notice
in place
uh that is held on in obeyance pending
the outcome of this decision
so moving on to the presentation
uh this is avondacek village and that is
the location to site where the black dot
is zooming in on that a little bit this
is the this is avon caro
a listed building and this is the
application site in red just to
distinguish it from the red building
further listed buildings are marked in
red over here
excuse me
dale i'm just going to cut in a bit
could you would you have to raise the
volume slightly because i think some
people having difficulty at the back
apologies just to jump in there yeah no
problem does that help
am i clear enough
can you bring them
here
okay join me to pause
i've paused
it's very rare for people to complain
they can't hear me
that's not normal
thank you
oh ready to go
okay
fairly loud
i'll have a go
fact oh
yeah
i'm conscious the time i think we're
going to push on um what we're going to
do is i'm going to ask dale to please
don't take offense at this he's going to
really raise his voice quite
substantially just like i'm doing now
okay
dale over to you
thank you chairman
uh so
here we are avon caro is the building
the the square building shown here uh
which is
marked in red because it's a listed
building the red line here as his
convention shows the application site
sorry my voice is dropping i noticed
uh further red
dots on this map are other listed
buildings in the vicinity
um that's all we get from that plan i
think chairman
photograph showing the same thing this
is the house built around a courtyard
this is the application site here and
there you can just see
is that any better
and there is the conservatory that we're
talking about
here's the house built around a
courtyard
okay moving on
um
this plan shows us
the elevation of the house prior to the
building of the conservatory and post
the building of the conservatory
i think the difference is is clear i
don't think i need to talk you through
that chairman
this is the
main range of the building i think the
quality of it is clear the application
site isn't on the main wing it's on one
of the side wings
which are were originally service wings
and here we now reach the application
site and the conservatory in its context
note the the quality of the detailing of
the the dormers in the eaves
uh in what is otherwise a fairly simple
service wing
this is substantially how the site would
have looked when the previous inspector
visited
moving on this is a close-up detail of
the conservatory showing both its base
and the flu
which emerges from the rear of the house
and turns upwards to plus through the
conservatory roof
and then this final photograph was
included to show the sort of changes
authorized and unauthorized that have
been made to the building and are
mentioned by the applicants in the
update sheet
and finally chairman
there's what seemed to officers to be
the main considerations with this
application does the proposal preserve
the listed building and its setting
if not are there any public benefits to
the proposed conservatory
and if there are do those public
benefits outweigh any harm to the
historic design composition and
detailing
and are there any reasons why members
previous decision
officers previous decision and the
inspector's previous decision were
flawed
so the recommendation is that the
application should be refused chairman
thank you thank you dale right we go to
our first speaker on this application
that's councillor uh daryl muffet please
from avon dassett parish council
welcome councillor
okay well you've got three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end uh in the last uh 30 seconds of
your time jump to give you a warning
all right i'll just chime in at that
point um in that case over to you
just press the button in the middle of
the microphone for me
perfect thanks better lovely thank you
thank you uh i'm here to represent uh
even
parish council
which is unanimous in its support for
this application
as a council we fully appreciate the
importance of protecting avon caro as a
heritage asset within our village
and the views of the planning committee
and the inspector
in refusing previous applications
we also understand why this application
has been recommended for refusal on
planning grounds
however
this committee has given great weight to
comments from residents when considering
planning applications
previously recently
when considering an application
for development alongside evan carro
attention was drawn by councillors in
this committee to the 26 objections
received
and comments were made to the effect
that these should not be ignored
well in this case
16 letters of support for this
application have been received
and that's unusual for a planning
application
many of them are from near neighbours in
nathan cairo
this together with the unanimous support
of the parish council
indicates in this case the community
including those who might be affected by
the damage to the heritage asset are
willing to tolerate
that minor damage on a temporary basis
the health benefits to the applicants is
inculcable
and while there's no real public benefit
other than showing supporters that their
voices have been listened to
the damage to the heritage asset is of
temporary nature
your officers report warns of the risk
of setting a precedent for other
applications
however such applications will come
before this committee and before that
the parish council
we believe that this risk can be managed
in the event of future applications we
as a parish council will object and we
expect this committee to use its powers
of refusal
there's widespread support from the
residents of avenda for this application
and we call upon this committee to
listen to us and approve the application
thank you that's all
thank you excellent do you have any
questions for the parish council please
councillor dixon
uh castle muffet you mentioned uh that
obviously you're very supportive of this
and the residents are supportive of it
but in the future you would be objecting
to any similar applications for
conservatories and the like
is the one reason that you are
supporting this the personal
circumstances of the residents it really
is yes
any other questions
no in that case thank you very much for
your time tonight if you just wipe down
the table and the
microphone switch please
thank you
so we'll move to our next speaker
judith christine carter please agent
for the applicant
welcome
hello
thank you so you also have three minutes
same rules apply if you'd remain seated
for any questions at the end and i'll
give you a warning at the final 30
seconds if that's okay
lovely in that case over to you
good evening um i want to start with
planning reasons
policy cs8 historic environment
states that
where a development proposal will lead
to less than substantial harm to the
significance of a designated heritage
asset this harm must be justified and
weighed against the public benefits of
the proposal including securing its
optimum viable use
harm to a listed building can occur in
two ways
one is physical harm to the fabric of
the building
and the other is to harm it by creating
a negative visual impact
the conservatory for avon carroll is
secured against its rear wall by four
wooden screws
the holes are in the water and not in
the masonry of that wall
the conservatory is only for a temporary
period
so when it is removed and the four holes
filled with matching water no one in the
future will ever know that it was there
therefore the harm to the fabric of this
listed building is not only minuscule it
is also totally reversible
the only people who can see the
conservatory are the kiplings and any
people who visit them
no one else not even adjoining
neighbours can see the conservatory
therefore any harm with regard to
creating a negative visual impact on the
listed building
is zero
since the conservatory was erected the
kiplings have through using less gas to
heat their home
reduce their carbon footprint by 25
that's quite an achievement i think for
a listed building
both the applicants have copd
the management of which has been held
significantly by the improved air
quality in their home since the
conservatory was erected
mr kipman also suffers from seasonal
affective disorder
therefore the additional light afforded
by the conservatory in winter months has
helped him considerably to cope with
this condition
the impact of the conservatory on both
the physical and mental well-being of
both applicants cannot and should not be
ignored
yes we should all care for and look
after our listed buildings
but to deny those who live in them a
better existence that is when they do
know how do do not harm them is not
acceptable
so as far as the retrospective construct
um retrospective construction of the
conservatory before avon carrow is
concerned
i can see no planning reasons whatsoever
that would prevent you from granted
listed building consent on this occasion
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee councillor dixon
you mentioned uh or you quoted optimum
viable use
um obviously
we are
concerned regarding the setting of
precedence
and therefore
uh would not uh optimum optimum viable
use be applicable to any other
application that was given here and
therefore the real reason for uh
the
support of this by yourself and
residents is the personal circumstances
of the occupants
is that the truth or is that or is there
something else
well the obviously the
from my perspective is the whole issue
of less than substantial harm
and on the scale of
very little harm to
the top end of less than substantial
i would say and the heritage impact
assessment if you've managed to if you
didn't have time to read that at the end
concludes that it is on that very very
lower end of the impact of harm scale so
when you set that in context and then
you look at the benefits
for the current occupants
then as far as i can see the weight
falls in that favor as long as you're
not harming the building which in this
case i believe isn't isn't the case then
you look at all the other benefits and
those should actually i think
be given greater weight than they
currently have been
okay i'm just gonna add one question if
i could of course you you've mentioned
the benefits to the current um occupy
the current resident there are there any
public benefits
to people beyond the current people who
live there
only in that there's no harm to the they
can't see they can't see it you know
it's not as though they approach the
entrance to the caro and there is this
conservatory sitting looking at
okay thank you very much
no further questions in that case
thank you very much if you could just
wipe down the microphone button on the
table thank you
i can open the packet
it was one of those
i shall help you leave one open for the
next person
it's not straightforward
all right we bring forward our ward
member councillor fielding
it's definitely recording so as long as
you make sure the microphone's on it's
definitely recording
sir yes this is good so counselor you
have five minutes um
you know the routine over to you thank
you
um
i'd like to refer to the legal case that
has um
started off on the
uh planning officer's comments the brown
ramwell the
decision in 2014 it was held the
desirability of preserving listed
buildings and their settings should be
given considerable importance and weight
when the decision makers carry out
the balancing exercise however
lord justice
lewis
in the in the court of appeal in 2016
stated it's clear that as a matter of
both of law and planning policies that
harm if it exists
it is to be measured against both the
scale of the harm and the significance
of the heritage asset
although the statutory duty requires
special regard to be paid to the
desirability of the of not harming the
setting of a listed building that cannot
mean that any calm however minor should
necessarily require planning permission
to be
refused
in the 20
20 20 planning inspectors report it
refers to the fact that they happened
that he appreciated the conservatory
provided giving it
additional living accommodation and
social benefits to the applicant and
that such space
has
been particularly of benefit during the
pandemic i also know the energy
efficiency benefits from the structure
and the subsequent benefit to the
applicant's health
the
energy
the energy efficiency developments are
supported by the council and the
pandemic will be with us for several
years
taking the peel comments made by the
planning instructor i would like to
point out
that he may not have been aware of lord
lewis ruling i bet the 2020 inspector
decision was made after the court of
appeal
the conservatory does not sit on a
concrete raft but is held in place by
four wooden screws into the mortar
i'd like to show you a video that i've
taken
uh showing the conservatory is that the
first one
you can see it's a bit shaky but it's
not details it's just holding it steady
the first shows from the rear of the
garden
the second video
or it's a still can you go back that's
it
shows is taken next to the conservator
and shows the very unsightly
images of downpipes electrical pipes
cable and sanitary drainage systems
third
taken next to the porch outside the back
door of the garden please note the
coloring of both the
um
porch over the back door and the
conservatory they both are
is that one is that a video that one
because that also shows on the other
side again
the
pipes and the pipe runs and electric
cables
the last video which is taken from
inside the building
uh i will show it's from the inside but
it looks out from the living room into
the porch showing good quality natural
light i will then swing around the
chrome conservatory into the living room
which shows how dark the room is without
having the conservatory in place
so it just
keeps on going around so
anyway i'll keep going the stable block
was done piecemeal
when a purchaser agreed to buy an
apartment the vendor gave it a purchase
number hence the crazy numbering
of the apartments
i have been involved in updating listed
buildings including national trust
properties where all the pipes run down
inside the property to conceal them
from the external or the outside of the
building you can see from the way that
the soil pipes are attached to the
northwest rear of the carib when
somebody purchased an apartment they
carried out the construction work
without a great deal of supervision
hence the elevation no longer retains
its original integrity
as for the reluctance to allow temporary
consent the guidelines from
historical england
on planning conditions for sncs
and lbcs provides this 30 seconds
massage limited
okay in conclusion the conservatory is a
flat pack unit
uh and it's therefore a limited number
of time
however the importance of is the health
and the well-being of the occupiers and
the requirements the district council of
race with regards to climate change for
good insulation the lbc
meets all of these requirements
and together with being at the low end
of substantial spectrum
i i request that it's approved and just
one thing that i would like to read out
from the historical and carbon how
historical i'm afraid council you your
time has elapsed but you are you're at
the five minutes i'm sorry i can't let
you go any further i'm afraid but i
think maybe there might be opportunity
for questions at this point from the
committee do we have any questions
for the ward member
would you say there are any interesting
historical aspects to this particular
application
got one more question from councillor
trump
from a historical point of view is
historic not historical historic point
of view if there's one thing you'd want
to say to us but you haven't been able
to what would you like to have said
all right
i'm to have to pause it i think probably
we're stretching the leeway of questions
at that point uh any further other
questions for the kept for the ward
member please in that case counselor
fielding thank you very much for your
time if you could just wipe down the
desk for us that'd be fantastic
okay so we've had all the speakers
members uh any points of clarification
for uh mr barker
any at all don't all rush at once
councillor dixon
it's a general question dale actually is
that
obviously it's a listed building the
residents perceive the whole as
currently listed but elements of it be
better and more important than others in
their opinion
are they able as a group of residents to
make an application to listed buildings
whoever controls the national heritage
to actually subdivide and actually
arrange for faces only to be listed and
other parts of the building to be
delisted
not aware of any such arrangement are
you ross
you could apply to de-list the entire of
the building but yeah to do list parts
of it no
and don't forget that once a building is
listed then all its cartilage buildings
are also listed
so
i think the answer is no to your
question
an interesting question though councilor
mills
thanks mr chairman um
um
i'm struggling to understand about the
public benefit can you explain that to
me
you said um
it needs to have public benefit this um
it's conservative is that what you say
yes jim that's that's that's exactly
what i'm saying um where
works are proposed to a listed building
they should preserve or enhance the
building
sometimes
for whatever reason i think um the the
agent made the point uh
no forget that let's not go down that
line
sometimes where works are carried out to
a listed building they will inevitably
cause harm to the fabric of that
building they will cause harm to the
significance of the building
in exchange for which you might be
taking a building that is a stable that
has no current value no current use and
turning it into a dwelling which will
therefore keep the whole building in
good order
into the future
therefore although there's some harm
from the conversion
there's a public benefit to keeping the
building in good order into the future
does that make sense yeah the the public
benefit is to the building
to keep it in good order
and that's what the inspector couldn't
identify from this application and
neither can your officers
okay i'll follow up on that tale very
quickly so there's a distinction maybe
you could just explain the distinction
between public benefit and the benefit
of the individual
applicant
yes chairman i i don't think i can
actually add a great deal to it beyond
that
i think it's it's fairly obvious that a
public benefit is a benefit that expands
wider than the the owner and the
occupier uh to and into the future
whereas in this instance we're seeing a
benefit to the current occupiers
right any other questions
yes sorry cat scouts i couldn't tell if
you're waving or not sorry all right
thank you um
the heritage impact assessment has been
mentioned we don't have that in these
papers do we
no chairman it's it's available on the
electronic planning system to read and
obviously officers have read it
and members could have read it at any
point they wish to
yes i think perhaps it might have been
helpful to have it in with these papers
um i just wonder if it if public benefit
could be
argued that if
um
members of our community stay in better
physical and mental health
there is less strain on public services
i'll just
throw that into you
i think that's probably more of a point
for debate later rather than a point of
clarification
but perhaps we have to think about that
because it might come back later i'm
happy to comment on it chair okay dale
but only that we have no evidence either
way chairman um we have what we've heard
from the applicant but that doesn't
amount to evidence
and for clarity there are no very
special circumstances mentioned in this
if you look at the report chair there is
mention of a letter from the doctor but
again if you read it the letter from the
doctor says that the applicant has
claimed these benefits the doctor
doesn't claim them on his behalf
i think that's the point i was trying to
get that's okay um okay right so anyone
any other points clarification go to the
debate maybe you want to start us off
capsule mills thank you
yes thanks mr chairman i mean this has
come to us before i as as we know
and
i have to think to say i i
personally i don't think this does any
any harm um to the building it is
of a temporary structure um
is secured by just a few screws so which
can
be taken if the next person moves in i
can be
taken down quite easily um
i seem to remember the last time it came
to debate i
did support the the application and um
chairman i'll not change my mind so i
would support this application thank you
mr chairman thank you thank you council
mills anybody else wishing to speak in
the debate on this one
councillor jennings
so come on okay
well i have a lot of sympathy with the
with the owners
um
and obviously
this is the third time it's come back
and
we're if we're going to go against
what we said before and the
um the
inspector's decision
there's got to be some good reason to do
that
um
this plan this planning application
hasn't changed it's the same one
um
i'd love to be able to find something
there but
i can't see it
um
there's got to be a public benefit to
outweigh the harm
i can't see it
um i'm really struggling on on that
um the fact that the building's got some
upvc or um drainage pipes further along
it doesn't do that doesn't change this
application
um i've got a lot of sympathy with them
but
um we can't give special treatment
to
one family
when everyone else staying in the whole
block could turn around and say well if
you're giving it to one why can't i have
that
and it's and there's no valid planning
reason to enable that
so
that's where i'm coming from and i'll i
will be
i will be going with the officer's
decision on this
regrettably but
it is it is
yeah accountability you want to do it
sorry to cut you off the councilman as
you indicate you want to come yes yes
please thanks mr chairman um there is
actually an another conservative on this
um on this site
um which nobody seems to
know what i'm probably about to say
though don't you
i think you probably know what i'm going
to say which is we have to consider yeah
well in front of us but there is another
one on this side
um i've got councillor dixon next and
councillor flemming
thank you chairman um we heard reference
made i think probably by the parish
councillor regarding the stance we have
sometimes taken on the number of
objectives and the number of supporters
and yet we are advised frequently that
the numbers don't make any difference
whatsoever it is the principles and the
actual
at planning aspects and the aspects and
legal aspects of applications which are
important
so um
it is regrettable uh that the
circumstances of the occupants are such
but essentially i too am supporting the
officer's recommendation and will
propose that we are indeed uh refusing
this application
thank you councillor fleming
yeah the the only thing that
i don't like about this is the fact that
it sets a precedent
the uh the actual
i mean i mean looked at all the photos
and whatever else
um this doesn't affect or impact anyone
else in terms of
human impact or impact on other families
and so from that perspective
i don't see where the harm is
okay we're here to protect buildings and
whatever else um but the the four screws
and a bit of flashing i don't think
actually are going to cause an awful lot
of harm to that particular building
um but the thing that disturbs me is the
fact that
we've already been discussing that
this could set a precedent for other for
other applications
and uh so i'm i'm really on offense here
which is unusual for me but uh
i uh i haven't decided which way i'm
going with this yet because purely the
precedent thing thank you councillor
foreman
thank you um i agree with councillor
fleming i think this is a really
difficult one i've got a lot of sympathy
for the residents and but i do
understand that this has come before the
committee before being refused and the
inspector withheld that and upheld that
sorry um but i can't make a decision at
the moment i am struggling with this one
okay counselor curtis
thank you um
just picking up some council of
fleming's points which i i agree with
and i
i would like to see this approved i i
must say um
we are frequently told in in this
committee that
we don't set precedence by making one
approval i think that's perhaps just
worth reminding
the
does it fail to preserve or enhance
i
i think we should be looking at the
wider context of what the rest of this
building does look like and in that
context i really cannot see
that this small conservatory
does any harm i think the pipe the
existing pipe work that's there already
does is it does far more damage um than
this particular thing and um
i i take the officer's point that the um
the
public health benefit is not proven but
it's not not proven either and i think
we as a council we have a duty of care
to listen to what that public health
benefit may be to these residents and
i would certainly support um the view
that councilman mills put initially that
we should approve this
thank you chair
okay thank you councillor crump
um i seem to have a different memory to
catch the curtis regarding precedence
i can't remember
saying that before but i might be wrong
but i thought that
other cases are normally quoted
in applications when something
the same or similar has happened nearby
so i i tend to disagree on that one
yeah i've got a lot of sympathy for this
case but you know um
and
you know i've been trying to work out a
way to try and improve this but like at
the moment i can't see it
i was an accountant i rely on evidence
and
if there was
strong evidence of the special
circumstances that have been implied or
we've been told about
we don't seem to have according to mr
barker a letter from the doctor which
categorically states
the
conservatory
would give
uh
okay
right
i'll go council jennings
then i'll have my thoughts
i mean obviously i've listened to
everyone here in the sort of
planning rules harden this or does it
preserve or enhance the listed building
the answer to me is no
does the public benefits
outweigh the harm
no
therefore i'll be going our second uh
councillor dixon's proposal
you beat it beat me to it i think you've
probably read my notes which are pretty
much exactly what you've just said which
are gone through it does it preserve
does it
no it doesn't
are there any public public benefits no
so i will also be backing the officer's
recommendation to refuse i understand
exactly what council trump's saying
i think i'd probably share his thoughts
as well if it came back with some other
other form of evidence
but right now that that's just not there
so
that's where i am
anybody else want to speak on this one
well let's put it to the vote then shall
we it's been proposed and it's been
seconded to refuse the application in
line with the officer's recommendation
all those in favor of refusal please
five chairman that's against
three german abstentions
one german okay therefore the committee
resolves to refuse application reference
twenty one
zero one
nine one nine slash l b c
okay
we move to item four on our agenda
tonight
which is found on page nine of your
agendas
mr german can i ask how cancer jennings
can read your notes as you're a teacher
my handwriting is perfect
exactly
right
okay give a moment for a bit of
shuffling to go on lovely right let's go
to item for them
this then is application reference 21
0 2 1
0 5
ful
this is for arden croft newnam henley
and arden and
yes the description is the change of use
from garage to commercial gym
health and fitness suite together with a
new external staircase this again is
retrospective
uh
presenting officer for this is joseph
thank you for you
thank you very much um
is that better
i think dale just wasn't shouting in the
mug
the site is located in the hamlet of
newham as indicated by the black dot for
you on the plan
the application is retrospective change
use of a domestic garage to a commercial
gym health and fitness suite together
with a new external staircase
so the plan before you indicates the
site
that's the application site and these
are the listed buildings indicated in
red arden craft rosemary cottage so
forth
the site plan before you indicates the
size of the development and the proposed
parking allocations it should also be
noted that the application site is
situated in the green bolt and although
the building is set within the set in
the neighboring listing properties it is
not considered to be listed in itself
for the reasons set out and the
officer's report
so as you can see on the plan
that is the proposed change of use of
the garage to the gym car parking area
to the front of the garage and as i
showed on the previous plan arden craft
and rosemary cottage are listed but the
building itself is not listed by virtue
of its age
these are the original plans that what
was
permitted and built just after 1993 as
set out in the officers report
and these what are the existing plans
are and what the proposed use will be
for this application so you can see an
additional staircase consultation room
shower room gym studio
parking area to the front also you can
see the change usage to the front
elevation to accommodate access into and
out of the fitness suite gym studio
this is a subject building itself
so the two staircase
and the access into the property
this is views taken from the road so you
see land side elevation of lane ends
cottage and view from the public realm
with the subject building just here set
behind the
small amount of trees
this is a solid elevation of lane ends
cottage
and this is the swept path nasa's
indicating access into and out of the
site as well as the parking requirements
and that's the end of the presentation
the proposed use is considered
acceptable in principle with the
imposition of the recommended conditions
as sat out in the officer report the
application would mitigate against
recognized impacts through those
proposed conditions therefore for the
reason set out in the office report the
application is considered for the area's
development plan
associated guidance and the relevant
material planning considerations i would
also like you to note there are updates
on the
update sheet
in the there was additional
correspondence one of the neighbors
regarding uh requirements of being
notified of the application
which
has been liaised with as well as
additional response
from a neighboring resident on the 8th
12th however no additional matters
not state when the report have been
raised
thank you
all right thank you joe okay so we'll
get our first speaker on this um this is
mr robert green speaking on behalf of
the residents objecting
welcome mr greene
so
you also have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end
we'll give you a warning in the final 30
seconds if that's okay
whenever you're ready if you press the
button in front of you then you can
begin
ryan thank you nunem is a small hamlet
with 16 dwellings
i should say that i need a picture of
your photograph here the hamlet is
located at the end of a three-quarter
mile no through road
access to the gym is around lane end
cottage my next door neighbor using a
shared private access gravel drive is
about 35 meters in length
four other properties are close by all
have written to the council complaining
in complaint
every vehicle
creates an extended every visiting
vehicle creates an extended 50-second
gravel crunch around my neighbor's
cottage including a three-point turn
as a grab as munum is a rural location
with one accepted to my launch all
visitors to this gym travel by car
the planning application now has a
specified condition of four people
in one hour sessions from 7 30 in the
morning to half past 8 at night i.e 13
hours this means upwards of 52
visits per day 4 times 13 using the
gravel drive and 16 on saturdays
to recap we have
extended hours of commercial activity
and noise
the primary victim is my neighbor
who is elderly it's it's causing her
distress as well as the five immediate
five and a half days a week from first
thing in the morning to lasting at night
her quality of life has severely been
impacted she cannot enjoy simple
pleasures of sitting in her garden in
the summer or sitting in a living room
without the crunch of yet another car or
four by four passing by
it is her first contact the enforcement
officer in april this is a rural
residential area not a commercial park
other reasons for objection include the
fact that this is a single access single
lane access road with no pavement no
street lighting no pulling places and
three blind bands and the 60 mile an
hour speed limit child safety has been
ignored
street lighting for so big on the street
playing for children has also not been
recognized there are 12 resident
children in our hamlet 6 under 11 and 6
over 11 ironically
also ignored we've also been surrounded
by seven listed buildings which has been
referred to but it seems to be ignored
again
unacceptably bright lighting also closed
during the two hours 30 seconds and this
has also been ignored 10 written
complaints have been ignored
and not one letter in support but one of
these objectives have ever received
notification of this meeting nor have
they received any correspondence at all
since subjecting
that's the driveway that is concerned
and i'm glad i've got it up on the
screen you can see the
geography of our uh of the entrance the
previous picture does not show it
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr green and you are spot on
three minutes uh any questions uh before
you go just let's check see if any
questions from the committee councillor
curtis
thank you um
you mentioned um i think that there'd
been a number of complaints there'd been
complaints about the um excessive
lighting
um could you just clarify
what that complaint was and what the
response from the council has been to
that uh well
that
um
on the right and the left hand side of
the two uh glass windows there are two
very high powered lights
um
you can't point that you can just about
see the one to the right of the white
box
and the one on the opposite side is the
same those are seriously high-powered
lights when anybody comes down the
stairs or there's also one on the stairs
as well when anybody configures in the
front of this building this light comes
on you know and it's a tremendous bright
light now it has been referred to in
here and it says it switches itself off
but when you've got people coming and
going and a time delay on it that it
stays on there's continue can you
continued length of time and it lights
up the back of mrs pascoe's house or
lay-name cottage and also the front is
so so bright so that's the difference i
would make to the light
cast curtis you're going to give a
follow-up thank you very much chet um
really my my my question was also
if there has been a complaint
to the council
about the lighting has there been a
response what was the nature of the
complaint and what was the nature of the
response thank you chair
uh well there's been so many things
going on i can't actually answer that
specifically
but yes okay we'll move on council mills
did you indicate earlier thanks mr
chairman um
hello mr green um
you're concerned about the traffic up
and going up and down the lane there um
there's a
um
opposite arden croft um
there is a business there is there um
when i went down to have a look over the
other side the lane the bottom there's
um
is it a farm or
do they
are they often up and down the lane
and i direct answer that question there
is a farm i found buildings there it's
just i won't say it's an active farm
opposite directly opposite my photograph
uh the house or the barn has been
changing or is being changed into from a
dairy into a house and it's not complete
yet but it's well on the way to be
complete the other two buildings are
basically just unused for storage but it
is an active farm to that extent
but there are there are vehicles coming
up and down but that also will cause an
additional problems i guess but in
comparison with the numbers i were
quoting they are knowing no significance
at all
okay any other questions
no in that case mr green thank you very
much for your time if you could quickly
wipe down the desk in the
microphone button for me that'd be
fantastic
thank you
thank you we'll call for our next
speakers then uh mr gary moss the agent
for the applicant and david shadlock the
applicant himself
welcome gentlemen so you have three
minutes between you uh how are we
dividing this up
who's speaking and harry speaking you've
got any questions perfect okay excellent
right well that case you've got three
minutes if you remain seated for any
questions at the end um
mr moss over to you thank you committee
um policy cs22 economic developments
allows for the reuse of rural buildings
for business purposes
my clients business is a small will be a
commercial gym operation that uses this
as one of many sites across the district
it's based on one-to-one training
and although has been pointed out there
are up to a maximum four people living
in one time per session in reality the
diary does not get filled up so
the concerns raised by the third party
in respect of there being four people
every hour from 7 30 to 8 30 is just not
realistic and it's not how the business
operates
um we've worked hard with your officers
to look at conditions to try and
minimize any impact there is on those
neighbours
um
my client
lives in arden croft is a neighbor
himself
um and obviously the last thing he wants
to do is upset all his residents albeit
still wanting to support his business
which in the current climate can only be
a good thing
also the type of business it is
lends itself well to obviously
addressing issues of social well-being
health obesity as it's based on that
type of operation
you'll note there is no objection from
any statutory council teams that
includes environmental health
and also highways
um
as you'll see from the number of
conditions and as has been outlined
quite clearly in the sections in the
officer's report we've been continuing
the
in dialogue with the officers in order
to ensure the development is acceptable
we would hope that based on this
officer's report and those conditions
that you can support this application
thank you
any questions from the committee
councillor crump
uh thank you mr moss um just a pretty
quick question and obviously think about
any commercial sensitivity or
confidentiality how far do the clients
travel to come to the to the gym
how far do they travel yeah where are
they from are they are they local or
whatever they're going to be local um
because we're a specialist we do have
people traveling football
okay thank you
councillor dixon
this is a retrospective application so
the gym is already i assume operating
that is correct yes uh can you tell me
for how long please
it's
two threes
did you hear that
two to three years
okay any other questions
council mills councillor curtis uh hi
guy um
so
how many times a day did you say this is
being used
on an average
on an average it just depends on a
day-to-day basis um but you know on a
good day we might have eight clients
coming on a bad day you know free fall
so you know on an average you're looking
at maybe six or seven people per day on
average
thank you very much just to add on that
bit um also there's the two sort of um
set up so you've got the downstairs gym
and then you've got the therapy room
um upstairs as well and i've understand
that the therapy room isn't actually
operating as much in
the gym so again the four people maximum
is the maximum number yeah
and finally follow up on that um
it's it it's all cut off time you know
what what time do
you finish in the evenings
we finish
because there was a concern about that
the lights coming on and these dark
evenings yeah but the light they're
talking about is a sense of security
light which i didn't install it was all
really existing
um
so
from that point of view it only comes on
when people come up the drive and
there's other people that come up or
drive including delivery drivers postman
you know you name it and actually part
of that is sort of health and safety as
well and also we have a reason to
protect our house and for security
reasons so i'm you know
if people come up or drive i want to see
them
thank you very much
uh yes councillor curtis
thank you just a tiny point of
clarification really if i can um
it says in here
somewhere um external writing is turned
off once the last employee leaves the
premises
can you just confirm is it are there
four spaces for clients and staff in
addition or if you just hire those four
people in total so if you have two
members of staff there they're kind of
gonna be there all day and then clients
will come in and out so the idea that
that traffic system which was clarified
mr green is actually rubbish
um you know the end of the day we would
have two cars there with staff and two
cars there for clients as
as gary has mentioned that we are only
using the downstairs at the moment so
it's typically two cars maximum one car
traveling in and out so that's the stage
we're at at the moment
any other questions
it was quiet in that case gentlemen
thank you very much you'd wipe down the
surfaces for me there and turn off the
mic thank you
okay we'll go to our next speaker final
speaker on this application council
foreman ward member
welcome council you know the routine
you've got five minutes over to you
thank you chair
i am also objecting to this
retrospective planning application
is newnan a rural residential location
the right place for a commercial gym
when there are several gyms available in
much more suitable locations such as
stratford or ulster
the development will have a severe
detrimental effect on the immunity of
the residents from noise pollution and
light pollution particularly to the
residents of the neighbouring properties
noise pollution will come from several
sources
firstly there will be a significant
increase in the number of vehicles
traveling through this normally quiet
hamlet because of gym staff and
customers
condition two asked for hours of
operation of the gym to be 7 30 am to 8
30 pm monday to friday that's 13 hours a
day but i'm sure the staff employed at
the gym will be arriving before 7 30 and
leaving after 8 30 p.m so the noise
pollution from vehicles will impact on
the residents for more like 14 hours a
day on a weekday and five hours on a
saturday
secondly the driveway off the access
road leading to the gym is a large
sloping gavel drive and creates
excessive noise when vehicles drive onto
it especially when they accelerate to
combat the slope of the drive
thirdly the slamming of car doors
potentially large suv car doors when
staff and customers arrive and leave the
gym
finally from noise pollution perspective
the deep bass thumping ghetto blasting
music that may be played during opening
hours condition 7 states that all
windows are to remain closed during
training sessions
the very nature of gym exercise raises
the temperature of the immediate
training environment and as far as i can
see the application makes no concession
to alleviate this
keeping all windows closed during gym
sessions is necessary to mitigate noise
but maturely create an unhealthy
environment for employees and gym users
and human nature being what it is
temptation will be to open windows while
gym activity is taking place this makes
this condition potentially worthless
moving on to the light pollution when
the gym is being used there is light
flood lighting on the outside of the gym
which will illuminate the immediate area
of the gym and will acutely affect
elaine's end cottage where one
downstairs room looks directly out onto
the gym and the old dairy where two
bedrooms look directly onto the site
this is bad enough during summer months
but the issue of light pollution will be
excavated during the dark winter months
the application reply
provides four parking spaces and states
that the largest vehicle to enter the
site relating to this development is
that of a private car
but the targeted users of the gym are
working professionals who are likely to
drive larger suv type vehicles i believe
the four spaces provided are inadequate
to accommodate such vehicles
also wcc highways have no objection
subject to a condition requiring
sufficient turning area to assure ensure
that vehicles leave the site in forward
gear
this is a shared driveway with the
neighbouring property and the turning
circular stations provide the turning
circle for two of the parking bays is
extremely tight and very close to the
parking allocated to lane end cottage
there is an external staircase at each
end of the building giving access to the
upstairs when standing at the top of the
external staircase on the right hand
side of the building you look directly
into the garden of rosemary cottage
which is a listed building
i believe this unapproved staircase
causes harm to the listed building but
this is less than substantial harm
however the imposition of a screen to
hide the garden from the view at the top
of the stairs is an ugly addition to the
landscape landscape and was brought in
loss of outlook for rosemary cottage and
can be considered as substantial harm to
the listed building
for the reasons i have stated the
building model fails to meet the
conditions conditions of policy as10 as
it and is unacceptable in this location
and unsuitable for the proposed use
the applicant describes his clientele as
working professionals that need to use
our services around their normal working
hours the applicant shows high regard to
his clients and i feel that same high
regard should be shown to his neighbours
it's disappointing that we are looking
at this application retrospectively for
the reasons given i would ask members to
refuse this application
if members are inclined to accept the
application i would respectfully ask the
application to be temporary granted for
12 months to monitor the conditions i
adhered to
and condition added relating to the cars
entering and leaving the site as
requested by wcc highways condition two
to be altered to hours of use 8 am to 6
pm monday to friday and 8 a.m to 12 noon
on saturdays this would include staff
usage condition three to be altered use
from eight a.m not 7 30 a.m condition
four to be altered to add abuse 8 a.m to
6 p.m that's performance i'm gonna pause
your day we've had five minutes elapsed
however could i'm going to start off
with questions can we go through those
suggested amendments again please
because i've not had time to write them
all down so if we start with that as my
first question for you is that all right
one would be that the application is
only temporary granted for 12 months to
monitor the monitor that all conditions
are adhered to
condition added relating to the cars
entering and leaving the site in forward
gear
the first one again please temporary
limiting temporary contemporary
condition of 12 months okay for 12
months sorry carry our apologies come on
that's okay uh it's probably because i'm
speaking too fast to get everything in
in the time
you keep going
so the next condition is relating to the
cars entering and leaving the site in
forward gear as requested by wcc
highways
the next one is condition two to be
altered
to hours of use
eight am to six pm monday to friday and
eight a.m to twelve noon on saturdays
and this would include staff usage
and condition three to be altered to use
from 8 a.m and not 7 30 a.m
and condition 4 to be altered to hours
of use 8 a.m to 6 00 p.m monday to
friday and 8 a.m to 12 noon on saturday
we got those because i don't think i've
got all of them
very quick again but i think
olivia's she's on top of this she's
better than me at this she's got it okay
so we can reflect on those later right
let's go any other questions from the
committee for the ward member
right council jennings first then
councillor nixon
um i noticed uh
the parish council
uh say that
they understand their economic reasons
for this development and
and uh therefore are not
not objecting to this application
i spoke to the clerk of the parish
council on monday night actually
and
they don't have any counsellors at the
moment
i think they had one at the time this
application went in so the parish clerk
was able to send in something but it
wasn't on the website so it hasn't been
put on the application
but she assures me they did not put in
no objection okay i think
we'll have to be careful because
obviously you're not able to speak for
the periscope okay but you guys yeah
it's all right um
but yeah members you know what
situations council er dickson then
councilman
thank you chairman
uh we heard that uh it's been operating
for two to three years
can you tell us how
this application came forward if you
know was it as a result of complaints
and objections through enforcement
through environmental health or did the
applicant suddenly decide oh we ought to
have permission for that i believe but
probably mr green could probably answer
it better than me i believe that the
residents um complained to the
enforcement officer
but then kovid came along and so the gym
closed and this has come back now
because the gym has now opened again so
i think it went to enforcement
okay
uh council mills
that was more and more that's my
question thank you very much thank you
excellent any other questions for the
ward member
nothing balance it council foreman thank
you very much for your time you're
already on the wiping down process thank
you for that right while you're doing
that let's move to points of
clarification anybody want to start
if you have any
no
council jennings
have there been any complaints to
environmental health
i'll be perfectly honest i couldn't
answer it would go straight
environmental health i'd have no saying
that whatsoever or planning would have
no saying that
okay any other points
so follow-up questions in that case but
environmental health haven't put in an
objection
no as you can see on the consultation
response there they've recommended the
condition but no objection to the
application with the stipulated
condition
so the presumption would be that they're
having a problem with that okay okay
okay anyone else points
to clarify no all right should we go to
the debate
who wants to kick us off
anybody in particular
anyone itching to speak on this one
councillor mills thank you
councillor fleming cats mills
a bit confused really with
the recommendations on this one to grant
and then the previous one was refused
we're talking about listed buildings
we're talking about things that have
happened without planning consent we're
talking about retrospective
um
it's
i know this particular module of the
building area isn't a listed building
but i just see the
far more harm in what's going on here
than what went on with the last one but
let's park all of that um i just don't
see how this how this is it fits
with what's what what's actually
happening um and it affects far more
people
people are objecting to this because it
causes nuisance
and so from my perspective i uh
i i wouldn't be supporting the officer's
option to grant on this one
thank you uh council mills you did
indicate a second ago
yes mr chairman i was i
when the applicant was saying that it's
i was the average of um
i've got did say eight times a day was
it was it eight times something like
that yeah so that's
16 movements isn't it in and out
um
average of six was it um i have to say
it it doesn't seem excessive to me but i
i would be concerned with them with the
lighting i mean that probably could be
pointed downwards so it doesn't affect
anybody um
but i i i have to say i i i'll go along
with your obvious recommendation this
one mr chairman thank you
councillor curtis and council jennings
thank you um
i was gonna go the other way around
sorry
sorry who wants to go no
oh god i'm going to pick right council
kids
yes
i i'm a little bit concerned about some
of the
negative impact on the neighbours what
slightly concerns me and i think
councillor fleming was sorry
um
castleformer was making this point
if i don't take words out of her mouth
at all but
there are a lot of conditions attached
to this
and
i just wonder if we
does this committee have confidence that
if this were to be approved
would all these conditions
be met
i i have very concerned about that
i'll come back really quickly then go to
duke council jennings i think that's
point for enforcement we don't it's not
for us to decide whether they're
legitimate or not but i think that's an
enforcement matter not for us
so if they we put in the
conditions that we think are necessary
and if those conditions are not met then
it's for people around that to take that
to an enforcement matter it's not for us
to worry about how enforceable they are
i think i hope i'm right on that
yeah yeah if i can just clap
we do have to be satisfied that
conditions are enforceable um but we are
satisfied that the conditions which have
have been recommended here are
enforceable um but uh the chairman was
quite right in that obviously if we do
get any subsequent complaints it will be
for our enforcement department to
consider how to respond to those
okay
all right
council jennings sorry for cutting you
off that's all right
um
and a lot of this seems to revolve
around the gravel drive
um but a lot of people a lot of people
have gravel drives i mean i can hear
my neighbors
coming down their gravel drive
and a lot of them have uh light sensors
i can drive down a road and all the
light sensors come on it's
it's just part and parcel of how we live
and especially these days with rural
crime it's something which is
is very necessary
um
i'm
to go against officers recommendations
we've got to offer
really strong material planning reasons
um
there's a bit of noise but we're in
there i've never seen so many conditions
before um and i know
and i absolutely i think it it's it
tightens up the whole application and it
and it and it's right
changing the times on it
i don't think
you're asking us to judge when a gym
should be open well i'm
i'm no expert on that i think we have we
have the details which the officers come
up with
and uh
and they they look
very specific and then no doubt they're
in line with when
small rural gyms
or i mean i go past them and then you
have pilates people are converting their
barns into pilates and
there may be
um
i say it seems to be very tight i don't
think we should be
judging on when it should be open up
what specific times that's that's not
our role
but uh so
with that in mind i'm i'm certainly
leaning towards uh going
with the officers recommendations on
this
thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman um
6 pm was suggested as the sort of the
cutoff time by our ward member
i think a gym or a health facility
operating until
20 30 20 8 o'clock essentially at 8 30
monday to friday etc does allow those
people who are still working till 5 5 30
to attend when otherwise this facility
would be closed um so i wouldn't be able
to support the uh
recommendation from our ward member but
i am nevertheless uh supportive of the
officer's recommendation and i will
propose that we grant this one chairman
thank you councillors that's the
in favor oh
granting yes cats redden
um unlike cancer jennings i do put a bit
of weight behind the
or more weight should i say um behind
the noise aspect of this um and i do
think that that in itself is a strong
enough reason to perhaps go against the
officer's decision um but i'm not going
to propose anything just yet
right councillor jennings
environmental health
are not objecting to this
so if they were objecting to this then i
would i would understand your argument
there
um
i'm happy to therefore
second promotion which has been proposed
to support to grant
thank you
um
i'll have my thoughts at this point uh
is do i think this is a perfect location
for this no
um but i'm struggling to find any proper
grounds here and we've got to make these
reasonable grounds to stop uh to stop
this i i'm just not seeing them
um i don't think the traffic movements
get of course substantial harm at all
and as council jennings said we all have
to put up with certain level of
intrusion from noise from light from our
neighbors i don't think this is going to
cause substantial harm to the privacy or
to uh to the setting of the environment
the local local residents here so i'm
going to be back in the offices as well
on this
in terms of looking at the change
conditions uh council reform i wanted to
make sure we took them down carefully so
we heard your your um
suggestions
again i don't i don't think they're
reasonable for a gym
especially in this day and age i don't
go to gyms myself obviously you can tell
that
but
i i do understand they operate into the
evening and if you do get home at five
o'clock then you know you're not gonna
get there in time for six o'clock et
cetera so you need to operate later
hours right okay i think anybody else
want to speak on this
right
we've got a proposition to grant uh
we've not amended any of the conditions
so let's go to the vote all those in
favor of granting please show
that's five german five those against
two german extensions
one german thank you therefore the
committee results to grant application
reference two one slash zero two one
five
105
f u l
and move to our final application of the
evening
oh
which is item five found on page
19 of your agendas
this application reference then twenty
one zero two three four four slash f u l
and that is for plots six and sarah s
sorry seven and eight saracens close in
eddington and this for the erection of
dwelling house and garage with
associated works
presenting officer joseph brooke again
joe over to you
thank you chef
the application is located in the
physical confines of eddington as
indicated by the black dot before
you this is the application site the
application is proposing a two-story
four-bedroom
dwelling within the red line boundary
it is located along
with scotland
so this is the actual application site
itself and gives the indication of the
block proposed block plan
these are the applications have been
recently improved and most are currently
on the development
this is a long let me make sure i don't
get that wrong along with nelson's close
kent's lane and old warwick road
this is the dwelling that's been
proposed itself stone slate roof
split face stone dress stone details and
uvv sash windows there are conditions
regarding materials and as recommended
in the officers report
this is the west and east elevations
and this is a proposed floor plan
this is a street scene undertaken
regarding the dwellings that have been
recently approved and under construction
some have been built
to the west of the site alongside so the
public footpath runs across the front of
the site
this is just an indeed indicative view
of the application
i do have some videos here
just need to get 200.
so this is taken from the public
footpath walking down i do
drill in front of you apologize is
completed and is being occupied
this is now coming down to the foot
class too nice and close
this is the actual actual application
site itself and this is the corner plot
of nelson's coast there
so we're now just entering into nelson's
close do apologize i probably should
have been a bit quicker
that's the plot itself
now we're coming into kent's lane that's
nelson close down there corner plot and
this is a corner plot ken spain
this is looking down canceling
and this is the corner plot that is
where the site will be
if permitted
this is then going into the access
between the site so the site is
obviously on your left that's looking
down kent's lane
back along
sorry that's looking down nelson's close
that's looking about down kensling
and that's the application so the
existing hedge
this is a corner plot
the application site is that here right
that's
corner plot again nice stuff for that
video let me just come out of that
that one pretty much to sin and this is
just a quick one along warwick's road
that's a long watch road let me just go
back to the
photos
caesar dwellings just
foreign on the video so i won't repeat
myself caesar dwellings have already are
been permitted and erected
once again closer views of the dwellings
have already been committed on site and
erected
this is down um
kent nelson's close that's the
application site in the foreground there
this is looking down um kent's lane
straight down application site you can
see why the plans are right
this is the corner plot as shown on the
video
once again this is your the other corner
plot along on kent's lane looking
further down
and this is on warwick road showing into
the uppercase site in the islands and
then looking down i'll right row and
public footpath run straight across
there that's the end of the presentation
thank you
thank you for that all right let's uh go
to our first speaker uh council rich
smith eddington parish council please
welcome councillor hello
right so you have three minutes
you
remain seated for any questions at the
end i'll give you a warning of 30
seconds all right certainly thank you
over to you
um once again eddington feels ettings
parish council feels that they've been
let down by stc planning department and
due to the way plot six on this
development was approved the section 106
agreement um apparently is now
unenforceable
and this has become a travesty for the
village with every application on the
site is now um
uh inconsistent in terms of the
parameters that were in the outline
planning
and are now not being met
we believe in the importance of public
participation are ndp and expectations
of the local community and the outline
for eight
uh modest
two-story houses
so we didn't object to this outline
planning application
um uh under which these this full term
is is being brought um this latest
proposal goes way beyond the remit of
the outline planning consent to take two
plots
uh flouts the existence of a legal
agreement put in place for the reason to
provide for genuine self-built interests
and the modest development which
would reflect local character design and
distinctiveness in this part of the
village
um the proposed design and materials pay
no heat to the local vernacular in kent
lane and nelson close for that matter
the village of eddington as a whole as
described
in the approved ettington and full ready
ndp 2011-2031
the proposed faux georgian design is
completely out of context with the area
of single-story bungalows and two-story
mid to late 20th century constructed
houses characterized by red blick and
brick and clay tiles
the street scene of kent's lane and
nelson close will be totally dominated
by this inappropriately large large
design
the spd clearly states the relative
position heights and separation of
buildings should be adjusted to reduce
overshadowing and loss of sight to
ensure that windows of neighboring
properties enjoy reasonable daylighting
proposed plans do not
comply with this
cotswold stone would have to be
transported a significant distance and
therefore is not local to the village
where most most houses are built of red
blick brick or blue grey stone
the proposed sighting of this property
will reduce the housing commitments
already allocated to the village and put
pressure on other land in the village to
come forward before strictly necessary
the local need was defined in the ndp
2011-2031 and the overwhelming choice
would be for more modest-sized dwellings
exactly what the original outline
planning set out to achieve
not one of not one substantially
substantial property across two plots
this would set an unwelcome precedent
for the remaining plots four and five it
is contrary to the government framework
council policy ndp guidance and most
importantly planning history at this
sensitive edge of our village location
the plans are not in keeping with as-10
they're not minimizing the impact on the
occupiers of existing properties in the
area it's over development of the plot
the hedge protection landscape corridor
noted a one meter wide hedge from hedge
maintenance i'm gonna have to stop you
there i'm very sorry we've just gone
over the three years possibly right do
we have any questions from the committee
yes councillor crump
hello councilman thank you um you
mentioned cotsworth stone a couple of
times about it not being um in keeping
with the rest of the
the settlement
um
i think on page 25
um
it mentions
uh the prominent stan is blue lice
limestone
and i think it says uh therefore
consider it prudent the condition is
invoked for scheduled materials to
ensure the development respects the
locality there if planning permission is
for coming so i think that might have
been covered obviously it doesn't cover
the other issues but i think that
condition about cuts or stone is is
covered there
i i i have to
bow to your knowledge of the of the
documents unfortunately we've had a
change of of hands
the previous counsellor who who dealt
with planning um is actually going to
speak for the members of the public
she's resigned as a counselor she may be
able to answer your questions better
than me all right thank you
all right yeah any further questions
okay in that case thank you very much
you'd wipe down the table for me that's
fantastic thanks
and we'll prepare for our next speaker
this is uh ruth hawksworth resident and
former parish council
thank you
so you can you can wipe that down
afterwards that's okay take a seat um
you have three minutes as well uh so any
questions if you'd remain seated at the
end for us please and i'll give you a
warning at the last 30 seconds if you
like give it a good press in the middle
hopefully the light will come on
there you go
all right over to you then thank you
good evening
um when the outline planning for
self-build plots was approved all the
documents for design landscape and
visual briefs indicated there would be
respect for local distinctiveness
character and appearance in this
location by the construction of eight
individual self-built houses
this is not the case with this
application
the topographical survey submitted with
the outline application proposed a ridge
height on plot seven and eight that
would tower two meters above nearby one
and two story properties in kent's lane
and nelson close which form their
locally distinctive design style and a
characteristic characteristically modest
in size and height
this visually dominating and out of
character development will overshadow
and be at odds with the original remit
of the outline approval of eight modest
detached houses
particularly when assessing the
application site against adjoining
highway and properties typical of this
location
to sink the property into the ground
will not lower ground level difference
with kent's lane and nelson close
locality
local dissection local distinctiveness
is within local policy and is the
ultimate test on whether the proposal is
acceptable in design terms with regard
to the impact of a proposal on the
character and appearance of the area
local distinctiveness can only be
defined from patterns evolved over time
in this instance the adjacent kent lane
and nelson close this application does
not achieve local distinctiveness
the single property proposed for plots
seven and eight will be 48 bigger than
the neighboring property to the west
in reality this property is 404 square
meters with the third floor left in from
the previous application but with the
roof lights now removed from the front
making it 118 larger
the planning officer states he is
satisfied the dwelling would not cause
an unacceptable loss of light or
overbearing impact dwelling to the west
but is silent on loss of light or
overbearing impact to the dwelling to
the east
this proposal will have a negative
effect and sit uncomfortably prominent
on the felden park sla adjoining open
fields and distant views of the
protected area
more modest properties nestle within
this sensitive edge of lake village
location with no adverse effect
in addition to any legal views and
policy conflict there is a case for
natural justice here there was a vision
when the outline development briefs were
drawn up that at the full application
stage the size and scale of the
properties adjoining the existing
streets of kent lane and nelson close
and character of the area adjoining the
eastern edge of the site
this faux georgian style three-story
dwelling spans across the whole plot of
plot seven and requires plot eight for a
driveway confirming the proposed
development is excessive over
development completely out of character
with the appearance of the adjoining
area and street scene wholly outside the
vision of the original consent for eight
self-built units
the current housing needs survey for the
village indicates local need is two or
three bedroom properties not mansions
which surely are a travesty of the cell
phone initially gonna have to stop you
there thank you love it
okay uh do we have any questions please
councillor dixon first
thank you chairman
uh
given that the outline planning
permission has expired and can't be and
therefore it is a situation whereby that
has gone within our updates we've
advised that
works had commenced on the site
um
are you aware of any
any works actually
on that site
or are
or were the parish council i know you're
not the parish council now but were the
parish council as it were relying
on the section 106 when it drew up its
ndp
because obviously the problem was and
joe will no doubt be able to expand on
it is when plot six was um
put forward and from what i've we've
the parish council have asked questions
as to why the section 106 agreement is
no longer valid and um it's to do with
the way that
um
the previous planning officer
um put that
dealt with that plot so it's effectively
to my i i don't i'm obviously not a
legal person but to my to my
understanding
it's the planning office's office's
fault that we don't have that section
106 agreement in place
so yes
it's not if we the parish council i
wasn't on the patch council at the time
it was it was sorted
but
we there was no objection made to the
outlying application because that
section 106 agreement
made sure that there were um people
could only buy one plot they couldn't
buy two and that they were of a modest
size the other the other ones that have
been built have all got
the one meter landscape buffer or
something from the outline planning
commission and they've all got something
within the um conditions of their
approval okay
thank you uh
cancer crumb i think you know what i'm
going to say that um it's just about the
condition uh the materials and and that
and the long hair no that's fine i
appreciate that that
i hadn't picked that up about would you
covered the cotswolds then i do
appreciate i hadn't picked that up so
thank you thank you perfect thank you
any other questions
in that case thank you very much for
your time if you give things wipe down
for me brilliant
yes we'll move to our next speaker which
is liz nicholson agent for the applicant
if you'd like to make your way forward
please
well welcome
you know the routine of course so you
have six minutes i'll give you a warning
at 30 seconds over to you thank you
chair i'm not going to speak for six
minutes and i'm just going to go off
message for a minute based on the last
question that you had
um my understanding of the history here
is the outline has lapsed because no
reserve matters applications were
received so
the outline can only go ahead if you've
got the detailed applications the
reserve matters come in and plot six
came through a full planning application
so that is completely separate to the
outline consent but i mean obviously
your officers will correct me if i'm
wrong on that but i think that's what
happened
um we're pleased to see that the
planning officer is recommending
permission to be granted for this site
the applicant has worked in a positive
and proactive manner with the planning
officer
whose hard work and professionalism we
appreciate in handling the application
the applicant entered into
pre-application consultation and has
responded to requests for additional
information and amendments to the scheme
during the course of the application
so this has included additional
information in respect of ground levels
and the height of the proposed dwelling
relocation of the proposed garage
changes the fenestration of the dwelling
and revisions to the boundary treatments
we're pleased to note that the principle
of dwelling is acceptable and that the
scheme is considered to be sympathetic
to neighbouring properties and the
applicant has worked hard to ensure that
this is the case
although of individual design the
proposed dwelling reflects the scale and
massing of other new properties built
and approved in sarasota's close
the main ridge height of the proposed
dwelling respects those other properties
the proposed garage has a lower height
and is at the side of the dwelling it
would be subservient to the dwelling
furthermore the disposition of the
proposed dwelling and garage ensures the
development will not have an adverse
impact on the amenities of the residents
of dwellings in kent's lane and nelson
close
the distance between the proposed and
existing dwellings meets the district
council's adopted guidance
high quality external materials are to
be used and obviously you've talked
about the conditions as well that would
control those and the site will be
landscaped to a high standard
existing boundary hedging will be
retained maintained and strengthened
the proposals meet the guidance in the
council's development requirements spd
including the provisions for sustainable
construction and climate change
so in conclusions the proposals accord
with the development plan and with other
material considerations and therefore i
ask you to grant planning permission as
recommended by your officers thank you
thank you in less than three minutes
excellent thank you any questions please
for the uh applicants agent councillor
curtis
thank you very much um
you mentioned that
your applicant has worked
very closely with the planning office
who complimented on his work professions
um have has the applicant or you as his
agent consulted the parish council or
the local ward member about his
application
i'm afraid i'm covering for a colleague
but i'm not aware of of a direct
relationship though
council dixon
thank you chairman
in our updates we are advised that work
has commenced on site now understanding
fully that uh reserve matters had
application has not been made
would you be of the opinion that work
had commenced on-site physically
i don't think that means on this site it
may be in respect of the outline
application which was obviously freight
but i think it's better that you're off
okay any other questions please
no in that case thank you very much for
the time if you'd like to give things a
wipe down for me thank you
all right we go to our final speaker
the board member counselor pennian
o'donnell
welcome council
so
you have five minutes to speak i think
you know the routine i'll give you a
warning at 30 seconds over to you
thank you good evening committee um so
i'm supporting the parish council in
residence who spoke so eloquently and
informatively before me
am i echoing um
i really feel i should ask whether
you're sitting comfortably or not before
we discuss the apparent fantasy novel
that is the ettington neighborhood
development plan and listen out for
three key phrases for me local need
proportionate dimensions and distinctive
local character
to imagine that once upon a time there
were committed residents who
collectively produced a vision for their
village and this included exciting
chapters especially around housing and
development if you look at their housing
chapter they told us that eddington
aspires to
thrive as a vibrant and distinctive
neighborhood to continue to respect and
reflect the views of its communities to
evolve and expand whilst retaining its
unique and distinctive character and
provide an outstanding quality of life
for current and future generations of
residents
and the community of eddington and fool
ready support this vision by supporting
measured proportionate timely and
sustainable development to meet local
requirements
whilst recognizing and protecting the
character and history of the
neighborhood area it's recommended they
promote new high-quality homes in
appropriate sustainable locations that
meet the needs of the village and
district without compromising the
distinctive and attractive setting of
the village or natural environment
of note is that nowhere in the
neighborhood development plan
does it ask for
large houses
that are three-story
and of georgian style what it was
looking for in the housing needs survey
was 13 properties of between for two to
three bedrooms and a minimum of two
bungalows that this application
absolutely flies in the face of that
nowhere does it highlight the need for a
three-story cotswold stone we know
that's now going to be changed um
georgian style property to add to the
overall look of eddington and this again
flies in the face of local
distinctiveness
nowhere does it request that each
distinctive road within ettington
village should be seen in isolation as a
silo of style where there's no cohesive
connectivity between established new
developments
the recommendation that the development
is in keeping with saracens drive is
polarized as it ignores a negative
impact this development will have on the
residents of nelson's close and kent
slain and i would urge when considering
this development you look at a 360 view
if we also consider what i understand
parish council is about to mention they
were concerned about the hedge
protection landscape corridor and noted
it to be one meter wide from the edge of
the hedge to hedge maintenance but this
had not been taken into account they
also noted they were concerned that not
enough importance is being attributed to
either boundary hedge nor maintenance of
ancient hedges and that the proposal was
contrary to both site history and policy
criteria laid down in policy cw9 and
parts d4 and m of the core strategy
but to clarify these residents are not
anti-development in this location just
this style of development
and with regards to the nppf section
three we plan making an early
proportionate or effective engagement
between plan makers and communities i'm
relieved to hear the applicant has found
the time and indeed the energy to liaise
with stratfor district council because
they have not found any time at any
point to contact the parish council or
the ward member on either of these
applications but what a relief they've
managed to contact joe
this application flies in the face
ensuring local distinctiveness and it is
not respectful of cs9 due to the lack of
sensitivity to the setting and it does
not respect minimum impact on the
character of the local landscape it also
is out of keeping with as10 as it does
not seek to minimize impact on occupiers
of existing properties
i do ask that if whatever reason you
decide to ignore the very recent
arguments of the pc the residents and
myself please ensure that in the
management plan it specifies respect of
the dark skies policy that time
restrictions are placed upon
construction traffic and deliveries and
that no construction traffic is allowed
on pence lane or nelson's close
committee there is an ever growing
concern amongst residents and pcs that
the expensive and time-consuming ndps
that we ask them as an organization to
complete and bolster to come to complete
to bolster their response to planning
applications and protect their villages
along with the consultations they carry
out such as housing needs surveys
they feel they are not worth the paper
they are written on in committee i would
suggest that to grant permission to this
application in this current state which
flies in the face of the ndp and the
housing needs survey would strongly
reaffirm at that point 30 seconds indeed
it's
disempowering our residents that we are
ignoring the ndp and the housing survey
to this level and committee i ask you to
please see sense and to refuse this
application
thank you very much
any questions for the ward member please
no none good enough likely excellent
that case thank you very much for your
time if you'd like to wipe things down
brilliant okay um
points of clarification anyone want to
start counseling mills
worry of activity thank you very much um
joe
it's been a lot of um
a point made about three story
can you expand on that is it three is it
two
um
are based on the plans before me so
those plans for me is proposed to be set
eight meters to ridge
with no dormer windows and we've and
only two four puns have been submitted
in so for my bases that's a two-story
dwelling
i will appreciate the previous
application which was withdrawn did have
dormant windows but they have been
removed from the application so we can
only assess what's been put in front of
us another minute that is a two floor
story to edit
and um joe may ask um
is the proposed developments um
uh how far is it from from nelson close
there's a house there isn't nelson
closer so the best way to do it is to
have a look at the residential mini
overlooking privacy and lost settlement
if you have a look it says about the
corner house on nelson coast to the east
so it's 11 meters to the side elevating
the cornice lebanese from the attacks
garage to the attacks garage
and the garage will be set at 5 meters
from the actual windows is 17 meters
away from the elevations corners with
the first
first floor windows
and the uh sorry mr chairman and and the
hedge that separate is going to be
retained
there's a landscaping condition for that
very sort of reason yeah landscaping
details and boundary details so we
retained and through the condition okay
thank you
apologies for the questions might be
being extremely dense here um outline
plan for eight but this side is using
plots seven and eight so there's only
going to be seven self-filled on there
rather than the outline
is that correct
yeah i think
the problem is i do have a lot of photos
but i think the best way to do is go to
the actual what was permitted in 2015
but has lapsed
in that
while you're finding that joe if i can
just clarify something and um the agent
helpfully clarified the situation so um
liz was quite writing that the 2015
outline planning commission has lapped
so there was a condition that required
the submission of all reserve matters
within three years and that didn't
happen so that's why the outline
commission has lapsed i think there's
been reference made to the update sheet
where a third party has said that the
planning permission was implemented and
therefore it hasn't lapsed but
no development should have commenced on
site until the reserve matters have been
submitted
so anything which has been undertaken
any on any of the plots across the eight
was done unlawfully so it didn't comply
with the outline paneling commission so
it has lapsed so that's just to clarify
that while while joe was finding the
other plan
just gonna pause for a second and ask a
bit of advice and i'll come to you
council jennings the ward member is
indicating she'd like to speak again i'm
right to say she can as long as it's a
point of
factual uh require clarification
very briefly
i think when ruth was speaking she'd
agreed with joe that a photograph would
be put up to illustrate her point and it
wasn't it was it oh did we just
sorry thank you thank you council
jennings back to you
on the clarification side obviously so
what you're saying is that obviously
because the the application lapsed we're
looking at this
purely on when take get rid of all the
history of all the other plots that's
got nothing to do with it we're just
looking at this as an absolutely new
application and that's what we base our
our brawling judgment thoughts on
correct
another point clarification yes thank
you
uh joe the um this new proposed
development is it
higher
than
the in nelson's close
it will be higher than nelson's coast
the reason being it's a step up from
nelson's close to the site levels are
different so there's no question that
would be higher than nelson's close so i
see this in the bad photo here as you
can see these two story dwellings here
thing the dwelling would be set there
and when you're walking up so there are
two stories away and set behind and
that's the property is round about that
so there's the side steps steps up to
the public footpath two the dwellings
are already on site so i have to admit
it will be higher yes and do we know how
much higher it'd be about a meter and a
half i go on the site levels looking
into it
slow jennings
but it's the same height as the house
next door in the bottom left so yeah
i mean if
it's twofold on that so let me same
again it's trying to show you all the
aspects of the site
so
there you go this is the site street
scene so it shows that it's been dug in
because i requested this to make sure
and that shows that all elevations are
fundamentally inside the same size along
sarasota's close
what the reason that i believe even with
the height discrepancies from nelson's
coast
kent slain is set out in the residential
meaning section in the you have to
consider the separation distances
between the two plots as well as the
field access
okay any other points of clarification
let's go to the debate
uh councillor dixon
i'm gonna say i i do sometimes have my
reservations regarding ndps because i
think
they are based on a situation where
they are drawn up by
well-meaning
volunteers
and essentially
i always think that within planning we
are advised sometimes that extension
should not be substantially larger
but substantially larger is never
defined
and i think the difficulty sometimes
with a situation whereby things should
be measured and proportionate and meet
needs
also requires either some definitions
so that we can actually pin people down
and they those documents i think always
invariably fail to be able to do that so
very regrettably
looking at this application we've got an
application for a large detached house
within the built up area boundary
and essentially i can't see a material
reason for refusal
so i will be supporting the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor curtis
uh thank you very much um
wow gosh
i thought
um
councillor o'donnell spoke extremely
eloquently and i would pretty much agree
with everything
she said um
it clearly this property this
application does not meet local need
according to the neighborhood
development plan
i think if we are to respect
local
democracy
we really do need to acknowledge that
neighborhood development plans
are put they may be put together by
volunteers
amateurs
but they clearly do represent the views
of the local communities and i think
it's
extremely tricky if we start
dismissing those um
it is a new application but it is
clearly in conflict with the
neighborhood development plan so i think
this i'm afraid i would vote to reject
this
thank you
councilor mills
thanks mr chairman yeah um
there are all different houses down
there um
and if you look around eddington
there is a mishmash as you come into
edington from
um
from the kinds of sides you come across
spit spitfire homes thatcher cottages or
thatcher roofs
they are a mishmash um
we're all different
i do
um counselor donald did speak very
eloquently on this um
at the moment i'm
i'm earned to go towards the officer's
recommendation i'll give it a think on
this one mr chairman thank you thank you
council jennings
well
we're looking at this application as a
fresh application
the site's within an adopted built-up
area boundary
it's in compliance with policy as10
which supports in principle the
development of new housing within the
built up boundary of the settlement
and it seems to accord with all the
other the cs15 says 16 as10 core policy
policy h1 of the ndp it seems to tickle
the boxes
obviously the other considerations the
design impact on the landscape and
character of the area
um
as as i often say
at these meetings i like contemporary
designs i'd like a bit more glass a bit
more l.a
to it but um
i don't have any i don't have any
problems with the design at all but i
certainly appreciate that you know
design is subjective
um but the ridge heights the same
i don't have a problem with with big
houses you know there is a demand for
big houses
um
the other
let's say we're going to the others
highways
matters we have conditions on that
um
loss of
privacy i'm struggling to see that i
mean when you look to the house which
was over to the right i mean it was
covered by trees you can't see that
there's one window
um
further away i'm struggling on that one
in planning there's a presumption in
favor of sustainable development
and
for that reason
i'm more than happy to say second the
proposal
of
not actually a proposal here in that
case i'd like to propose that we
that we go along with the officers
recommendations to
our grant
thank you
um my thoughts at this point then i'll
go to people who've indicated well i
agree with you uh i don't feel that
there's enough grounds to go against
this and as you've correctly said
um design is subjective i think and as
councilman said there's a range of
different styles in eddington and again
like like we've already said i mean you
know the
size of the house again it's to a circle
whether it's substantially larger than
it needs to be again it's subjective
i don't i don't find this to be
substantially larger it's big but it's
not it's not weighing in my mind too
much right um
with that in mind you know what i think
i'll second you actually i'll second the
application of the promotion so proposed
and secondly grant go to councillor
curtis and then councilman's thank you
very much
um there may be a need for
big houses pick up council jones point
but this large house does not
meet local need and it really does
concern me
that we seem to be if we
vote
to approve this development that we are
absolutely ignoring the work that's been
put into the neighborhood development
plan we're ignoring the representations
of the ward member and we're ignoring
the representations of the local um
parish council
and that really does in this particular
instance that really does give me course
of concern so i wouldn't be supporting
this application
thank you i've got council mills then
council planning
yeah thank you chairman yeah the ndp i i
think is a very important document that
um
same thing happening in kind where it
was almost torn up in an application
um but in saying that there are some
very large houses in in um
in eddington um they're saying going
right from the extreme end
is a difficult one um
again i think i have to go with the
office recommendation on this going i
said the size of the houses in uh in
edington they are quite substantial
thank you
all right i'm going through my list i've
got councillor fleming next
um as
one of these well-meaning individuals
who spent three years putting together
an ndp
and also who relies heavily on local
housing needs i think the fact that
the committee thinks it's right to drive
our coaching horses through those and we
talk about other applications say is
there a housing needs pla housing needs
documents yes there is so we should you
know we should take note of it and then
we say is there an ndp we should take
note of it and here we are ignoring both
documents i'm not saying it's wrong
to to give those full weight every
single time and we have we have to look
at you know we have to take each case on
its own merits but the whole point about
it is to say that these two things not
should be ignored but should be
disregarded i think is is is very poor
for the people that put the effort in to
do those um so from that perspective
um whilst i don't disagree that this is
a nice house and it fits in with the
other stuff um i just think that the
method we're using to choose it is wrong
okay i've got i have got a list but
alice wants to come in very briefly on
the points have just been raised
thank you chairman um i think there's
been some misunderstanding in terms of
what's proposed in terms of the type of
development so um this is a self-built
dwelling rather than a local needs
dwelling so we're assessing it in
different ways so i know you're making
reference to specific local needs in the
ndp and saying that it doesn't comply
and that we require a housing needs
survey to evidence a local need
that isn't the requirement here that the
development is within the built-up area
boundary of eddington and therefore we
don't look at the local needs part of
as10 um we look at the the part which
says that small scale housing schemes
within the buildup area boundaries are
essentially acceptable in principle so
there's no requirement for it to meet a
local need so i just wanted to clarify
that before we started going down down
that route
thank you chairman i'm running through
my list i've got councillor sorry i just
can cancel the crump next then i'll put
you back on the list all right
thank you mr chairman oh yeah but
certainly i've got concern about the
lack of consultation with the ward
member and the parish council which i
think is poor uh and it should be uh
should be noted
and obviously yeah i was confused i've
saved them earlier about the uh not
confused according um
about the outline plan lapsing and the
numbers uh
not been being seven rather night um
just taking analysis point about housing
need compared to south build
which is obviously a very pertinent one
um i don't particularly like this and i
have would have difficulty supporting it
but i'm not sure whether i can go
against the officer's recommendation but
it is a difficult one in my opinion
okay next on my list is uh where am i
jennings apologies take me a while to
get to yes sorry
i was actually just going to
raise the point about the self building
yeah okay it's been raised council
reading did you indicate no it's okay
councilman's then thanks richard i did
what alice was saying so
is this not
flying in the face of um
the ndp then this
not not in my opinion no and and that's
how we've obviously argued in the
offices report did you want to come in
there joe
i'll just clarify if you look at the
principal development the officer report
the ndp does stay two seconds for
confinement that he is outwarded
the application site is contained when
he adopted built a period boundaries of
edited and amplified by policy h1 the
estimate for the ndp moreover the site
is recognized within the ndp for the
allocation of health housing as depicted
in figure 2 the village boundary
for that reason it is within the ndp and
therefore an as10 and hey h1 is
considered acceptable in principle yeah
i'm yeah i'm all in favor of ndps and um
yeah okay
right i'm going to try and draw the
debate to close i think we've talked
around this so council dixon your last
one let's go for it
thanks chairman
when
ndps are being drawn up it's a question
to the officers
could
residents localities communities
basically give some restrictions on the
extent of self-builds and on the extent
of
uh development so that an ndp could
actually say
we will
or or we will not accept any four or
five bedroom homes in order to ensure
that that not just local need but for
everything can they actually do that in
an ndp
i'm happy to answer i used to lead on
ndps in my previous jobs planning policy
fundamentally no you can't have a
planning policy is allowed to be that
restrictive
the reason that you won't see it in the
mvp you won't see it in any ndp's you
went to the core strategy the reason
being it has to meet the test is
tiredness the tested soundness require
the policies to be flexible and approach
what they can do is put in encouragement
policies or encouragement guidelines
saying in these these requirements these
is what we believe the area is defined
in what you can't do is just say there
is an absolute ban on five bedroom
houses or four-story houses you can say
that the character of the area should
match there should be certain ridges and
stuff like that you can't have a blanket
ban on development
right okay so it's been proposed and
seconded that we um go with the officers
recommendation of grant
i think we go to the uh vote all those
in favor please
that's four chairmen
that's against
three german abstentions one german
no two german
well
there we have it then the
committee has resolved to grant
application reference twenty one zero
two three four four slash fu l we have
no urgent business for the evening so
five past eight we'll close the meeting
thank you very much everybody